hey what's up everyone how are you guys
doing hope everything is fine wherever
you are this is again
spanish grandmaster pepekwenka and i
welcome you to this lecture
games of the week as you guys know
not so many tournaments are taking place
right now because of the pandemic
because of this bad situation
but norwich has actually happened in
norway in estabanger extremely beautiful
place i don't know if you guys been
there
but it's definitely a place to visit and
also very very very expensive right
norway remember i was there for a
weekend when i finished my studies the
university when 2010
and i went there to celebrate and then
you know
i spent like all my morning one weekend
there you know i took a taxi i had the
nice idea to take a taxi like
two kilometers and uh you know it cost
me like a hundred bucks you know so
all right so uh magnus carlsen
before this tournament he has a
fantastic before actually he this game
he had uh managed to achieve a fantastic
unbeaten streak of 125 games
without losing a single game
so pretty amazing and this straight
ended up here and it was ended by a
duda super grandmaster from poland very
young
player and his top 20 25 in the world
um for sure will will will
will hear about him a lot in the in the
following years so just uh hello to
everybody out there
in the chat so i hope you guys interact
with me in this lesson will be fantastic
because it will be more fun i'll be
asking you some questions
and please don't hesitate to ask
yourself some questions if you have any
doubts
about any position or any line i'm here
for you guys
okay what's up piyush everything fine
so let's start with the game duda played
e4
and magnus calcium replies with c6 it's
very interesting because
in this norwegians we have seen like the
karo khan
being played in uh in several games for
example adi alireza firoza
the young star from iran he actually
employed it um as a main line um
in the whole tournament and magnus
carlsen has been you know
deciding between sicilian also karokan
and of course e5 the most solid approach
for black in
against e4 but in this case he went for
the
karaoke streak was unbelievable yes i
mean there have been
there have been other players for
example ding learn
he managed to get 100 games without
being beaten
and also segati biakov but of course uh
i mean uh this was in open tournaments i
mean of course
it's a great success but it's not the
same i would say because magnus carlsen
or
dillian they've been facing like 20 700
players during all these games so
pretty amazing thing all right so c6
here
uh this is the karokan defense eg
ej sorry so here different ways to play
for example c4 aiming to go for the
panel
variation d4 is the main line this is
what duda played
but also you can try knight c3 after d5
knight f3
i actually like this idea this uh this
variation
i actually employed it against a
stefanova ex-world champion
just uh two three weeks ago in the
spanish national championship in tins
actually we made the dragon but i was
putting pressure
this is another idea and you can also
try to go for the trip if you are
playing bullet
in leeches chess 24 or chess dot com you
can try this like knight g7 queen e2
and then you hop for knight f6 and then
you check my team
not going to happen very often perhaps
you can try so
c6d4 d5
and now players play cairo to get
unbalanced
sharp positions right no more solid
boarding that's right
you get a lot of unbalanced positions uh
uh
when playing the karakan knight c3
here again many players employ the
advanced variation with
e5 after that black can reply with
bishop f5 or
c5 some people say that karoka is a
better version of the french
why because you put the bishop out of
the pawn chain
with e6 right so the french is basically
the same kind of structures
but with the bishop on c8 which is a bad
bishop that's why in many cases
in the french black tries to exchange
this bad bishop for the good bishop on
f1
i would say both openings are extremely
interesting to play yeah
i've been playing myself the french for
many many years
okay so e5 does the advanced variation
for those people who like adventures
we just had a class about mihail tile
you can try this variation with f3
is much more aggressive you want to
continue with knight c3 bishop e3
queen d2 on long castle okay knight c3
mainline
dtx e4 knight x e4
and here the main line goes after bishop
f5
in this moment magnus carson decided to
go for knight f6
after bishop f5 you can try different
options here for example knight g3 is
the main line
after bishop g6 you guys know what's the
main idea
in this position for white
how to play here with the white pieces
this bishop is actually
very strong so that's why in many cases
you want to trade that bishop
and many people try here the move h4 h5
h6
h5 just fix the structure over there
that's ryanish
and money that's right and now you trade
the bishop with bishop d3
you know this pawn on h5 is doing a
great job
because he's fixing the structure and
then in some positions you want to go
with knight f3 bishop d2
long castle and then remove this knight
from g3 and then strong attack
on the key inside because you've got a
breaking point here in g5
where you can try to to create some
troubles but at the same time this pawn
on h5
could be a weakness actually in some
potential end game
okay there are also different ways to
play here for example knight e3
followed by knight a4 is actually very
interesting and even here this move
knight c5
has been tried as well for some players
okay so knight f6 from magnus carlsen
knight xf6
and etex f6
gtx f6 also possibility here even more
double-edged than eta xf6 because now
uh black actually more or less lost the
right to castle because now
castling on the key inside is gonna be
uh
very risky many in many cases right but
in return black has this open file to
put pressure with the rook
okay so it takes f6 and then we have to
talk about this position a little bit
because if we talk about
structure white has the better structure
right because
black has double pawns and in some
potential
end games again white would be able to
create a passport very easily on the
default
but in the same time what uh what's in
favor for for black after this like well
now
uh black just develops this bishop just
in one tempo
in the normal karaoke you have to waste
like 210p with e6 and then bishop g6
and okay c3 for judah
because he wants to develop this bishop
to d3 this
this way you reinforce the pawn on d4
and now black plays bishop g6 in this
position
bishop d3 castle and then how do you
want to continue
with the white pieces in this position
you want to play knight f3
you want to play queen e2 you want to
play queen c2
h4 h3 bishop e3
a4
how do you want to continue not a three
that's very reasonable ph 92 i think all
of them are perfectly playable yeah
in the game um duda went for queen c2
which is a natural move he puts pressure
on h7
and here you would be surprised the main
move is actually h5
in this position sorry rookie 8 first
rook e8 knight e2 and now h5
we could think that h6 is maybe more
natural right or even g6
but the point with g6 is now you can try
to
play on the key inside with moves like
h4 h5
actually this position is quite flexible
in the sense that now
white is able to go for long castle then
start an attack
on the key inside so that's why g6 looks
dubious to me you know
after h4 h5 then some sacrifices
arise on g6 right so it's actually quite
dangerous for black
so that's why you don't want to create
this
h5 break for white so that's why you're
going to protect
this pawn on h7 f5 still not possible
because of bishop takes f5
so that's why h6 or h5 i think both of
them are playable but actually
with this pawn on h6 there could be some
sacrifices
as well from this bishop on c1 right so
that's why people normally play h5 and
then in some lines if white wants to go
for shark castle
then black could try to attack with some
h4 and h3ads so that's why
h5 is is normally played normally played
sorry
nowadays so bishop e3
knight d7 and short castle
so now magnus deviated from the main
line what do you play here with the
black pieces
just give me uh a way to develop
your pieces for example it looks like
white has a perfect setup right so while
this is bringing his skin to b1
then white may think about putting
pressure on the key inside with moves
like
h3 g4 even knight g3 you intend to jump
to f5
right all these ideas are very very
reasonable in this position
so yeah b5 this is a move actually
it's not the main move there was only
one game before this game
where black tried this this line it was
actually a game between assad off
and robin van kampen robin van kampen
very nice guy
i shared him with him in the bundesliga
like for two three years
and he's a very strong player actually
he plays the kings indian
and i was checking his repertoire and he
helped me a lot actually with this
king's indian repertoire
c5 well c5 you have to be extremely
cautious with these moves
you know because whenever there is a
rook like
in front of your queen don't try to open
that line because something happened
could actually
something bad sorry could actually
happen to you so here
let's just open the file knight takes e5
for example bishop takes c5 bishop takes
e5 and now what's the ba-boom here in
this position
what's the baboon how do we finish
yeah bishop 87 this is pretty easy right
bishop eight sevens that's why
be careful with opening lines where uh
there's a rook in front of your queen
just uh take and
take that in mind so yeah so
normally black plays in this position
not a fake
black side is just to develop bishop
with bishop b6 then this knight is
controlling this focal point h7 right
and yeah this is perfectly playable and
this is healthy for black two but magnus
he uh he wanted to have a pretty
complicated game so that's why he plays
b5
and now blacks black has an idea behind
this move what do you think is black's
idea for example if i just
play kim b1 in this position what do you
think magnus wants you to do in this
position
with this move you are not only starting
a pod match on the queen side but also
you are gaining
full control on the live squares
so it's black storm what do you play
here
b4 well before i'm not so sure about
this move because i can play c4 and now
you're never going to attack my my my
ken sorry
because these files are closed and then
i have even more control in the center
so i don't like b4 actually
but nice suggestion pierce
am i pronouncing correctly your name
piyush
knight b6 that's right mihalys yeah
knight v6 is very strong
now you see there is full control on the
light squares for example
this knight can jump to d5 and then this
visual can come to e6
and white actually can't use his
majority
on the key inside or the center right
because these pawns control
very nicely the light squares so that's
why
duda plays very dynamically
fighting against this plan so
why to play in this position there is
only one good move actually
in this position who guarantee white uh
a nice advantage i would say of course
the position is extremely messy as you
guys are gonna see
so rook b8 well it's it's white's turn
right now right
so how do we play in this position
what should we play here with the white
pieces
well black wants to go knight to b6 and
knight d5 so
we have to react quickly in this
position
a4 well a4 you know a4
a4 looks very very you know
risky like normally you don't want to
open
uh the a file in this kind of positions
right
so i don't like a4 at all d5
abram that's that's right d5 and
basically this is almost winning upon
because now if black tries to play c
takes d5
then we just capture this pawn on b5 and
oh well we can also play something like
yeah bishop b5
or even bishop h7 followed by rook d5
attacking this bishop aiming to go
rook h5 so that's why black can't take
on
on d5 and if black goes for bishop c6
then we just win a piece in this
position forcing moves again
bishop h7 king h8
and gtx a6 4c moves checks
and captures why not g4
g4 wow very aggressive move
g4 actually is very interesting i guess
black should actually close the position
with h4
because if you take on g4 i like your
idea maybe you want to continue with a3
very interesting suggestion
i think black can still close the
position but
very very interesting
sarang
so in this moment as i told you
judah plays a d5 and magnus i think he
uh he's still uh i mean he uh
he was in his uh in his book still right
he was
this was all preparation because now he
sacrifices the pawn with c5
bishop takes b5 and rook b8 and
position is very very complicated
because now
uh black has sacrificed a point but in
return
it's got the b file open to attack the
skin
so now how should we proceed you want to
play c4 you want to play bishop takes d7
you want to retreat the bishop to c4
you're going to choose between these
three four options also bishop d3
now give me the best move for why
there's only one good move here in this
position for white
g4 was grandma's suggestion actually i
didn't know
there was a fantastic commentary on
norwich's vladimir kramek and
uh judith polgar they were doing
commentary together and uh yeah i also
managed to saw some
some clips and it was just fantastic
right g4
wow and uh just liked it when you just
suggested in the chat yeah
g4 very very interesting actually
bishop a4 queen d3 queen d3
i mean this smells bad right queen d3
smells bad because of knight e5
and then you're gonna retreat your queen
and then this actually
falls this bishop of v5 is just falling
so you kind of go queen d3 in this
position
um bishop c4
i don't like it either because of knight
e5 again and then you
have to lose another tempo by moving
this bishop actually after bishop b3 c4
and then you just gave
black so so many tempi in this position
so there's no need for bishop c4
that's right so yeah bishop d7
i don't like it you know i i always tell
you that the bishop bear is extremely
important and in this position i mean
black has so many attacking ideas let's
say queen a5
followed by bishop of a4 forcing b3 and
then
c4 and something's bad's gonna happen in
this position so that's why the best
move
is c4 that's right
reinforcing the center protecting the
bishop
and after this move magnus carlsen
went for a6
and now again where should we go a4
or c6
c6 or a4 well
i think both of them are playable but i
guess
bishop a4 is a little bit better why
because normally normally this knight
would love to go to e5 at some point so
basically as you're gonna see
magnus carson's plan is to play rookie
seven so this way he frees this knight
and then this knight is aiming to go to
e5 so if the bishop is on a4
you're actually not attacking the bishop
if the bishop is on c6 the knight on e5
is actually attacking the bishop
so i think bishop a4 kind of wins the
tempo
but of course these are small subtleties
and maybe
they are extremely important but these
guys are able to see all of them you
know they're super players of course
so do that place bishop a4 in this
position
and now yes i told you magnus goes for
rook e7 so now it's our turn
with the white pieces how should we
proceed like
uh i mean you want to create an attack
on the key inside you want to bring
bring the rook to the center you want to
improve
the er e2 knight
yeah that's right matan but if he moves
the knight you take the rook but what i
mean
that after rook e7 this is the move that
actually magnus carlsen played
now if the bishop is on c6 after next
black's move
knight e5 the bishop on c6 would be
under attack so that's why on
a4 is a little bit better
f4 wow f4 be careful i know facundo
usually solves the problems but not here
because we just blunted the guy here on
e3
so no f4 in this position
ashish
f4 what else knight g3 i see some knight
g3 ideas
yeah you will love to play f4 of course
you will love to play f4
then therefore this knight is i mean
it's not so good but
it's actually not possible knight to g3
i think this is the best move in this
position this is what
duda played finally because you're not
only
aiming to jump to f5 but also
you're attacking the pawn on h5 and this
actually looks like
you know tougher black right now
so what do you play with the black
pieces right now
how do you stop knight f5 and knight to
h5
you have any ideas in mind yeah bishop
f4
also after rookie 7 be careful with
these moves you know
now boom rook takes c2 and bishop f4
two pieces for rook white is much worse
so
be careful with these moves so
knight g3 how do you play g6
okay this is the first moves that that
comes to my mind
but it's a possibility but i just don't
like it you know i just don't like it
i can't maybe um i don't know play
something like bishop d2
then your f4 idea followed by f5 also
the bishop is coming to c3
but it's definitely a possibility
probably the the second best move in the
position
but there's a better move knight to b6
somebody's suggesting
the knight on b6 is the well it's well
placed because you're attacking the
bishop on a4 i guess bishop
c6 this was uh
magnus carlsen uh sorry uh judah's idea
probably
and in some positions it's actually very
interesting to take this bishop on e3
i've seen this kind of of ideas in the
benoni structures
right where the dark squares bishop is
actually a
fantastic piece so this could be one of
those positions
where it may be interesting to sacrifice
on e3
but okay so knight b6 is another
possibility
and rookie five rookie five i don't know
about this move
i don't know what what is the rook doing
on e5 yeah you are trying to stop knight
f5 but i just don't like again
for example bishop d2 followed by f4
you're going to end up losing another
tempo
so i don't like rook e5 i think the rook
doesn't belong to that square i think
e5 belongs to the knight so
magnus carlsen actually played knight e5
and then our question is what happens
if duda takes on h5 he didn't take on h5
why
why didn't he take on h5 in this
position
basically knight e5 is topping knight h5
but why what's the reason behind
exactly be used exactly be used
because there is bishop g and now black
attacks the rook and the knights
so that's why he didn't take on h5
but instead he went for knight e4
in this position and now you know
white is just aiming to put pressure on
c5 to put pressure
on t6 maybe get the bishop
and now it's magnus carlsen turn
so what do you think about this move
bishop f5 which looks like pin in the
knight on f4 you like it
you think it's a good move it's a bad
move
or what knight bishop f5 in this
position
or give me some candidate moves bishop
f5
i don't know g6 f5 what do you want to
play here with the black pieces
it's a bad move because there is
knight f6 in this position 4c moves
again
takes some takes and then this game is
under attack basically
well still knight c4 is not so clear but
i think after bishop c2 something like
this
there are gonna be some nasty threats on
h7
so that's why he didn't go for bishop f5
so what do we play then with the black
pieces
i mean this rook on e7 was not only
allowing
this knight to jump but also it has a
purpose
itself f5 is another possibility i guess
i can just take
on t6 and
this bishop is locked now by his own
pawn so
usually you want to bring this bishop in
the future to f5 right
by playing f5 this is not going to be
possible anymore
so a 5 thing is not a very good move so
rook b7 that's right this is the move
that magnus carlsen played rook e to b7
and actually
um is threatening some stuff for example
if i just play
let's say f4 what do you play here with
the black pieces give me the sequence
give me the sequence
yeah you can bring out the bishop
because the queen is attacking
f5 but in the future in the future there
will be some ideas with bishop f5
you want to play f5 in these positions
because the bishop is
never going to have a future you know
he's jobless he didn't go to university
you know basically it's not he's got
nothing to do just play bullet only
chess
the whole life you know which is fun you
know but it's may not be the
may not be the best you know
idea that's right rook takes b2
i think you missed the last move because
of takes takes
kin takes now knight d3 is not the best
move but instead knight c4 and then
grabbing this guy on e3
and then basically white is losing so
definitely
black is threatening to take on b2 we
have to take measures against this move
so
how do we react against
rook takes v2
i mean what do we play here with the
white pieces
b3 it's an option probably
the only option available here for white
because after bishop b3 i mean you don't
want to play this move right
maybe a5 a4 bishop f5 is also now
interesting
so because now i mean bishop f5 is
possible because there is no knight f6
because the queen is now
capturing on f6 that we're gonna set on
e7 didn't allow
this but now
that there is no rook on e7 so queen
comes to f6 and
actually black wins the game so you know
b3 best move here from duda
and now magnus carlsen goes for rook b4
in this position
so here duda has to play very precisely
the position is so complicated that the
engine says it's
completely equal 0.00 but of course this
is a
real mess yeah and
in this moment judah didn't go for this
move but what happens
how do you think would have magnus blade
if white goes for rook h to e1
so how do we play with the black pieces
yeah i see some interesting moves there
knight g4 rook takes a4
bishop f5 basically i like both of them
i like bishop f5 i like rook a4 let's
try to understand why somebody's
suggesting rook
queen b6 here which i think is not very
good because you are not on time to play
slow because of
f4 or something like this let's say
knight before and just a bit of d2
and i think white is much better in this
position so
you are not on time to play slowly in
this position
yeah so knight g4 same problem i can
just take on d6 and then if you take
there is a bishop d2 again so you
shouldn't allow this so rook a4
this was actually magnus carlsen's idea
and now after btx e4 just rook before
again
idea is just to grab this guy on c4 with
fatal
consequences for white in this position
right so the king is
extremely unsafe here and let's say if
knight d2
yes you managed to protect the c4 pawn
but all your pieces are very passive
look at this rook on d1 is
basically reading the newspapers yeah
and now
you can improve your pieces bishop d7
you're gonna take on a4
this queen is coming to a5 as well you
got a fantastic knight on e3
that is threatening to fork on d3 at
some point
so that's why um do that
didn't go for rook h to e1 now that you
have seen
what's the idea in this position how
would you play
with the white pieces i think this is
called reverse thinking or something
like this i don't know
so how should we play here with the
white pieces
knight c3 okay this is a possibility
to stop this i don't like knight c3
you know why because of the g6 the
bishop comes to f5 this looks terrible
for white actually
this looks very terrible for white so
yeah that's that's great bishop d2
just covering the b4 square very
important
because now magnus is actually forced to
to sacrifice the exchange otherwise
after rook b7
i mean there's no point to play rook
before and then after bishop d2 play
rook b7 now white can continue with
f4 just winning some space bringing a
rook to the e file
and then white skin is extremely safe on
the queen side right so
there's no reason to go play rook b7 so
magnus had to go all in
at this moment and he went to to take on
a4 rook takes a4 b takes a4 and now
bishop f5 from magnus
carlsen and he actually
has a lot of contemplation and a lot of
compensation for the sacrifice exchange
now duda was one point out but now of
course he's got double bonds the king is
very very unsafe i was pretty sure that
magnus was
gonna win this game i don't know why i
felt that you know
but i'm always wrong
so again what do you play here with
white
give me some moves some point you have
to reinforce your position
yeah we can remove the engine bar view i
mean we can do it like this
boom there's no engine engine bar
anymore
knight takes e6 don't blunder the queen
my friend aniket
knight x6 bishop takes c2 right
and rookie one
that's about that judah played in this
position pawn to f3
this is another possibility i guess what
black black is trying to do
is maybe to bring
the queen to b6 also bishop e4 is very
very interesting because if you take
with the queen maybe queen d7 moves like
that
queen d7 queen b7 later so for example
queen d7 queen c2
queen b7 you're actually threatening to
take on c4
and i don't see a clear way to stop that
so actually black has a lot of ideas in
the game
yeah f4 i don't like f4 you know
i don't like f4 at all you have
different options here
for black the thing is i understand your
point but i think black can play queen
b6 if you talk
if you now take on e5 there's bishop e4
coming
[ __ ] of e4 and there's queen b2 if you
take back on e4
right and then if you protect on e1 then
how do you win the game with the black
pieces forcing moves again
so you see that there was real danger
behind
duda's position you know what judah
means in spanish
like doubt or question mark you know
yeah knight d3 knight d3 only move takes
and queen b2 checkmate so yeah
magnus went for sorry duda went for rook
g2 e1 which is
very interesting because at some point
this skin
could be running via d1 right at some
point i'm not saying now of course
skinny one it looks like a terrible move
but at some point the skin
could escape by a d square
all right so in the game actually magnus
now
made a mistake according to the engines
i mean it's so easy to make mistakes in
this position so
again what do you want to play right now
be careful
because if you move the queen for
example queen b6
now this move has a hidden plan
not only to protect the e4 knight but
also
another interesting idea let's see if
you find the idea for example after
queen b6
so actually rookie one is a fantastic
defensive move from duda
yeah another six be careful with this
move g takes
queen takes queen b2 akin d1 um
you may survive and maybe not there's a
knight c4 coming
yeah rook e3 this is why this move is
such a great move because you are not
only protecting the knight on e4 but
also you want to come to b3
and block this file so rook d2 e1
in my opinion is just a fantastic move
that's right guys rook e3 very good
so in this position magnus has
a unique move to equalize the game it's
very tough to
to spot you know let's see if you guys
are able to see it like give me some
candidate moves in this position
don't tell me h4 this is that magnus
this is the move sorry that magnus
carson
went for h4
so how do you play with the black pieces
rook b4
yeah maybe this is too much you know
bishop takes b4
and now i don't know f4 this looks too
much
too much now it's a whole rook
knight g4 camilo andres drago
queen b6 queen b6 we just explained the
problem behind that right because rookie
3 and rook b3
take the knight take the knight i don't
like this you know because you just gave
up the bishop
and you got nothing in return and then
this was one of your key pieces
to create troubles on white skins
white skin sorry so nobody should take
c4 that's right the move
was knight g4 that's a fantastic move
because actually
now white is in a lot of trouble in this
position
i mean your thread is very simple you
want to play knight f2
and if you go something like i mean
there is also
another idea behind knight g4 is to free
the square
for the bishop and once the bishop is on
e5
rook b2 it's a real threat
in this position so it's actually tough
to play for white in this position for
example let's say rookie 2
bishop e5 and black sweater
so what else can you play here and also
knight takes f2 is a real threat for
example you play bishop c3
then how do we play here with the black
pieces
okay we don't have the e5 square but now
we have another important square
now we check your games your move sorry
sarang we'll check f4 right now
very interesting suggestion
so now what do we play with the black
pieces
knight f2 knight f2 just queen takes f2
and now the rook is protecting e4 so
knight
two doesn't work no
yeah bishop f4 that's right the bishop
stopped stopped covering
d square and now actually this king has
to run
through d1 and i don't know about this
position but it feels like
what should be doing very very fine in
this position
i don't know you have so many ideas even
like
some knight f2 followed by queen a4
check when when you capture followed by
some queen
rook b2 i mean some tactical shots arise
in this position
so not bishop c3 and f4
actually yeah this is a nice idea but i
think you can play knight f2
i mean knight f2 the threat is not only
taking the pawn but going to that square
because the knight on e4
is actually pinned so
yeah so after knight g4 i think the
engine was suggesting something like f3
and now you're gonna move with the black
pieces
how how should we proceed with the black
pieces in this position
well we have not so many options right
because our knight on g4 is under attack
so
yeah bishop e4 that's the best move
because now we are forcing
yeah knight f2 here uh it's no point
because now rook rook f1 knight takes f4
f takes f4 you want to keep the bishop
probably on this diagonal
but i think after bishop f4 something
like this
white has reinforced the position
there's no trouble
but bishop before the point is white
cannot take with a piece
so basically this file is gonna be
closed
and after pawn takes e4 some mobs like
queen e8 for example
attacking a4 also aiming to go to e5 we
can use this square for the bishop or
for the queen
let's say a3 queen e5
because we are threatening actually
queen a1 and i think the ending was not
finding anything better just just going
for the repetition bishop d2 queen e5
bishop c3
and i think black's fine in this
position but okay
so knight g4 very deep also not an easy
move to do
and magnus as you can see magnus also
human being and he went for h4
and this gave white enough time to
reinforce the position
now we said that knight g4
was a interesting move for black so what
do we play here with the white pieces
f4 f4
f4 yes okay f4 attacks the knight but
then we can still go to g4 i mean it's
not a bad move
but yeah pawn to f3 pawn to a3 pawn to
f3
allows h3 and then f3 suffers
so that's why h3 is much better than f3
we stop this h3 idea from magnus carson
g3 i don't believe in this movie because
there is knight f3 coming
and uh yeah shouldn't allow this you
know and then bishop b5 and then same
ideas with rook b2
so h3 very good move from duda
now khalsan went for knight g6
now magnus wants to use this square for
the bishop
and what should we play now again
remember this defensive technique from
do that defensive move rook d2e1 was
made
with more than one purpose not only
protecting the knight on e4
but also aiming to protect the third
rank so that's why rook e3 was played
here from duda
now magnus carlsen is struggling in this
position actually see he went to play
knight f4
in this position attacking g2 and now
this is a very simple
move g4 for judah
now of course after taking on h3 and
pass on black white recaptures with the
pawn
and why it's fine so magnus carlsen went
back to bishop g6 with bishop g6 sorry
and now his idea is to open the position
up with the move f5
so what do we play now with the white
piece it's not an easy position
we have interesting options here
several playable alternatives for white
but what do you think about this move
rook b3
you like it yeah knight d6 again be
careful with your queen
and it get the knight is pinned so you
cannot take on d6
so rook b3 the problem is that
you stopped covering the square and 92
and 94 could be actually very very
dangerous
so rook b3 is not very good right now
that's why
duda plays queen king d1 a move that
it's
amazing because now he's covering e2
and now he's ready to to go to b3 if
needed
magnus carlsen here tries to create some
mess by playing f5
trying to open the position it makes a
lot of sense actually the engine doesn't
like this move i mean
i think the engine was suggesting
something like bishop e5
and then or queen d7 two f3
but magnus carlsen opens the position up
with f5
and anything actually can happen in this
position don't believe
don't trust always in the engine you
know i mean i'm sure
i get to play this position against
magnus cars and i lost
10 out of 10 games
that's right so
now f5 knight takes d6
and the thing is black cannot play the
intermediate move f takes g4 because
there is rook e8
just winning the game so that's why
magnus carlsen
went on to play queen d6
and g takes f5 from duda only move from
magnus skulls and bishop h
a5 and now best move
for white f3 and queen f6
basically black straightening to
penetrate
on a1 so that's why duda played bishop
c3 stopping that move
so queen g5 and now there are some nasty
discovery moves with the queen on
g5 right something like knight d5 is in
the air
so that's why duda centralized
his queen by playing queen e4
and now magnus carlsen played queen g2
and this is an extremely important
moment
what do you play here with the white
pieces i'm gonna tell you
my threat is just to take the rook of
course but also to take the pawn on a2
and now you have to find a concrete an
amazing solution
that do the found and this way he just
won the game
it's a fantastic tactical sequence
yeah push pushka you were actually
talking about any conspiration
but it was also the answer to this so i
thought like you were
i mean anticipating the future you know
i couldn't i couldn't understand what
was happening in the what was happening
sorry in the in the chat actually
double rook on e1 and then after queen
takes
a2
so basically this move is the only one
in this position
and now the engine suggests for magnus
carson
f6 which nobody understands right
we'll try to understand later but the
point is
magnus just played queen a2 in this
position
and actually he was thinking he was
winning he thought he was winning in
this position
because it's not easy for white because
there's rook b1 coming
and if you play queen c2 it looks like
black can take on c4
right and then there's some check on ea
i'll just take in h7
looks like black skin is fine
queen e5 there is checkmate on b1 so you
cannot go for
this i arrived first with rook b1
so just try to find the solution i was
very impressed because duda found this
solution extremely quickly
in that game
so any ideas
queen c2 and if i take on c4
what happens queen c2 i just take on c4
and now what looks like black's winning
you gotta find something concrete
yeah queen c2 but then what queen takes
e4
and it's not clear
rook e8 takes
take skin h7 and then
and then what you're almost there
you're almost there bishop d2 i mean
this is too sad
yeah it's just rook b2 for example this
is just losing look at
how the bar had a heart attack after
bishop d2
that's right guys you saw that pretty
amazing combination i mean i was very
impressed
when duda played extremely fast queen c2
here in this position
magnus thought he was winning but the
problem with queen c4
is that there's this nice tactical shot
rookie 8
now magnus played king h7 because he
realized
that if he takes on e8
then there is rookie 8 king h7
and then the final blow
the final shot come on
defeat magnus carlsen beat magnus
carlsen how do you do it
rugged shade that's right rook h8
fantastic move
king takes h8 and bishop g7
sayonara baby king takes c7 queen takes
c4
and black has to resign
so that's why magnus carlsen already
noticed that he was losing actually
after this trick on h8
that's why he tried key h7 okay
rook b8 and then he's i mean he's
completely lost
he kept fighting in this position he
took on d5
queen d2 bishop takes
f3 king c1 and queen takes f5 i mean
dude is so much material up yeah it's
got like two rooks for one night
it's true that the king is a little bit
shaky on c1 but
you know this is just uh too much
material so let's see how the
game finished so rookie three at this
position attacking the bishop
and covering d3 which was magnus scouts
and threat
so let's say if you play something
stupid like a5 knight d3 and probably
blacks winning so you gotta be careful
till the end of the game
so um
rookie three knight e2 from magnus
carlsen king b2
knight takes c3 where this
not much going on queen takes c3
attacking the bishop queen of four from
magnus causing attacking the rook on
b8 queen d3 check f5
facundo this time not enough to solve
black's problems
rook f8 okay discontinued a little bit
more
but i mean it's not really interesting
because the game is completely lost for
magnus carlsen
he took on e4 finally sacrificing an
exchange
and now is only one root cap in this
game
so some more checks you can always check
for a few more moves but after king a5
took on a6 now magnus carlsen tried to
push the pawns but this is just
too much and finally he resigned because
he was
actually taking the queen on f5 next
move
okay so this was the game that
ended magnus cause an unbeaten strike of
125 moves
two years without losing a single game
in a classical
chess tournament facing 2700 players
all the time and uh we have to say that
he actually lost a second game in this
same tournament against
levon aronia we actually analyzed that
game the other day in the class
in the end game class so basically
magnus carson losing two games
in one tournament this is not a very
common thing to see
okay guys so it's been a fantastic
pleasure to be here with all of you
i guess i'll come back to the youtube
channel in couple of days
for the next lectures where we'll have i
think a chess for rookies
chess for nights and uh
puzzle paradise as well where we'll be
solving some interesting puzzles so
i hope you guys have a nice evening and
take care yes stay healthy that's a more
important thing
just take care guys see you